so how can KFC have the fastest
drive-through times unless you meet
unless you mean it's faster because
there's never anyone in the drive
through because KFC sucks and everybody
knows
Chick-fil-A has the slowest
drive-through study says I ordered
something from KFC drive-through six
years ago and I'm still waiting for I
still haven't gotten it KFC has the
worst customer service of perhaps any
company that has ever existed on the
planet like their employees openly
despise you for being there like when
you're walking in you see the employees
moving around and they're not moving
around very fast but they're moving
around faster than when you go up and
place the order now they slow down on
purpose you order a bucket of chicken
and you sit in line for four and a half
hours and when you get to the window the
guy opens it up and then he he spits in
your face and hands you like an old shoe
with some ketchup on it and if you say
well that's not exactly what I ordered
he'll just roll his eyes and there's
nothing you could do because he's also
the store manager somehow that is
literally the KFC experience literally
that that exact thing has happened to me